ladies and gentlemen let's give a warm
welcome to angelina jolie who has
officially joined instagram and true to
form she's using the platform for good
shining a spotlight on what's happening
in afghanistan
a source close to the oscar winner tells
et quote angie felt compelled to join in
a moment when women and young people in
afghanistan are losing the ability to
communicate on social media and express
themselves freely from her point of view
if she's able to be a part of the effort
to amplify their voices then she felt it
was reason enough to join and use her
platform
it feels powerful it's hard not to in
her first official post to instagram the
46 year old actress shares a letter from
a teenage girl in afghanistan alongside
a caption that reads in part quote it is
sickening to watch afghans be displaced
yet again out of the fear and
uncertainty that has gripped their
country to spend so much time and money
to have bloodshed and lives lost only to
come to this is a failure almost
impossible to understand
she concluded her lengthy post by vowing
i will not turn away i will continue to
look for ways to help and i hope you'll
join me as a special representative to
the united nations high commissioner for
refugees angie has lent her voice to
several humanitarian efforts over the
years including domestic violence
awareness and empowering underserved
women as well as saving the bees
i'm always learning trying to be better
and try to be honest
there is no denying that angie is a
strong woman who uses her platform to
inspire change and when eti spoke with
the oscar winner back in may ahead of
the release of her film those who wish
me dead she opened up about going
through a period in her own personal
life where she felt broken and how she
channeled that energy into her role to
make her better we all have times in our
lives where we feel
broken
and uh
i was in a period like that
my share of of things that have made me
feel um
you know
hard to
speak too much about it but just
overwhelmed or broken
to have an opportunity i feel very lucky
i wish all women could have this at
times in their lives all people when you
feel like you just want to kind of hide
under the covers or you're not sure what
you've got left in you i would encourage
anybody to go somewhere see what you got
in you put yourself against the elements
or try something you've never tried and
kind of try to rediscover that
that strength within